I was asked a question yesterday which I
wasn't prepared for so I just gave the
first answer the template on my head
which is a fine answer that was driving
everyone was rattling around in my head
for a little while so I want to come
back to this guy because I wonder if
there's um I'm more elegant explanation
for it I showed you the pattern you're
like oh I don't know I'm not that
convinced I want you to see one more way
that you can philosophical factorials
wait effect or has come up in maths like
they're not just oh this is cool this is
interesting what kinds of areas of math
to come up in permutations and
combinations right in arrangements so we
do things like this we say um you know
if you've got four spots and you have to
put four people into those spots how
many different ways can I do it right
and of course you can think about it
like this well let's take before of them
and think well I can put any of the four
in this first spot right when I look at
the next spot I don't have that many to
choose from anymore because I've just
put one here so there are we three that
I could put in that spot and then there
are two and then there are one so that's
where we get all the possibilities
that's 4 factorial right so another way
you can define factorials is not just
it's this multiplied by all of the
integers down to one right you can also
think about it as 4 factorial is the
number of ways to arrange a certain
number of objects right in this case it
was 4 yes okay
so when you come back to like say a
simple case where like you know one
factorial of course it's one when you
think of the original definition but
it's also one when you think of this
when you have just one object how many
ways can I arrange this how many orders
do I have and the answer is one right
okay
so if I have no objects how many
different distinct orders do I have I
have one here it is that's it that's it
right there's no way I can rearrange
this where you look at at my my my zero
object to say oh that's a different
order of your zero objects right it's
still the same order there's none of
them right so being that there is only
one possible way the number of ways to
arrange your objects is one okay so if
you weren't pleased with my pattern
forming yesterday then maybe that's
another way to look at it okay
it's really important that you don't
just say ah rules are rules
because math machines always have a
reason for it